what's going on everybody welcome to
part 10 of the Python 3 basics series we
have been working on our game of
tic-tac-toe up to this point and in this
video we are going to be determining
whether or not we've got a winner or at
least one of the versions so but centex
we haven't even done user input yet
understand that's really gonna be like
the last thing that we add so if you're
wondering when that's coming or if it's
coming it's definitely coming it's going
to be a full game of tic-tac-toe I
promise but really to test all this
stuff it would be really tedious to like
enter in all the little inputs along the
way so we're really just gonna kind of
hard code the game and do the testing
and then at the very end we'll add in
actually you know giving user input so
in order to validate whether or not
we've got a winner of the game of
tic-tac-toe there's really you know
three maybe four ways to win the game of
tic-tac-toe for via programming three if
you're just explaining it to a friend so
the first way is you could win
horizontally as player number one has
done here write this row you can also
win vertically so if you know this is
all the same or these are all the same
or these are all the same you won the
other way is diagonally so that's of
these three are the same or these three
are the same okay
that's how you win now just like the
other things this is like these are
clearly subtasks so determining winner
breaks down into three three like
subtasks of programming like basically
it's gonna take kind of three different
algorithms to determine you know is
there anyone that won horizontally
anyone vertically anyone diagonally and
arguably diagonally depending on which
way you calculate it might take actually
two different two different algorithms
ding time to code okay so let's handle
four horizontally so how might we handle
horizontally well I can think of like a
few different methods like one way we
could do that is by we could go row by
row and then maybe for each element in
that row like we could set like some
sort of flag and then what we could say
is like for
each element in that row if that element
equals row maybe a you know row and then
index zero if all of those equal row
index 0 then congratulations you've done
what you intended to do now if not if
that's not true then no one won but
that's gonna get like really messy
really quickly not really going to be
the most ideal way for us to do that so
the next week a programmer might come up
with doing this would be something like
this so let's say define when we're
gonna pass a current game because we've
decided that's the way we're gonna do it
and then we're going to we're gonna do
like something like this like four row
in game and then we could say let's just
we could print the row but then we're
gonna say you know call one equals row
zero and then we're gonna do the same
thing for two and three so call to call
three row one two and then at the very
end well really in each for loop not
really at the very end if call 1 equals
call two equals call three
hot-diggity we got ourselves a winner
okay cool
so win and then game is what we call it
right game yeah so run it boom we got
ourselves a winner congratulations
player number one now what's the problem
with this though so like let's say let's
say we actually write this code and then
we write this code for like all of our
you know you know you could do this for
all the verticals you could do it
[Music]
surprise that happen again
thank you Noro I'm not really sure how
to pronounce that but thank you for your
support
anyways back to we were doing so with
you know we can do it this way but what
happens when your boss comes to you and
says hey Johnny we really like what you
do with the 3x3 tic-tac-toe make it a
4x4 now and then you're like date and
then you're like okay but that's okay
that's okay I will just go into my code
and changes in super simple right but
then what happens when your boss comes
back and and don't forget you've done
this now for however you decided to
calculate vertical and diagonal then
your boss comes back and they're like
hey Johnny um can we make the game size
of tic-tac-toe dynamic and at this point
you are going to have a pretty big
problem because you've hard-coded this
so then you might be thinking well I
can't do dynamic but what I can do is I
could have a separate tic-tac-toe game
for each size of tic-tac-toe like I have
a 3x3 version I could have a four by
four and five by five and all that like
I could just have a separate script and
that's not good that's what I would
describe as disgusting okay but through
my career of doing contracting and
salting for various companies I've seen
people do that I've seen people have a
thousand or more variations of a script
that is otherwise identical except for
like one variable change don't do that
that's called technical debt and you do
not want it like the first time you
program something like that okay I guess
maybe you'll get away with it but then
over time as things change where you
need to make minor changes suddenly you
need to write a Python program to make
the changes so this isn't ideal so we
know because we've talked about
repetition and stuff we know this is
probably not right then we are thinking
okay well what if what if we do do that
initial idea where it's
like you know we iterate over the rows
and then maybe not match flag could be
like false and then whoops so a not
match flag is false in the for item in
row we could say if item equals row 0 if
I'm already confusing myself now uh if
item how about if item does not equal
Rho 0 not match equals false
no not match equals this is our equals
true okay then match it was false non
match equals true so if if not Matt if
not man this this was really poorly
written print winner what am I doing
wrong I thought that was gonna get away
with that call one not defined
well where's oh oh who's down here for
some reason okay okay apparently they're
all winners this isn't even what I
wanted to spend my time doing but for
row in game how about all match equals
true for item in row if all match equals
false if all match print winner that's
probably a little better but again we're
still having like this whole equals what
are you talking about
if item
or item in row print item and then row 0
if item so 1 1 1 should be a winner but
here this definitely should not be a
winner all match
if item
Oh double equals false come on man
okay try again idiot okay so so here we
have this this is the basic series by
the way okay so okay so this was that
double stupid double equals um still
still tagging me after seven years okay
so so in this works right and this is
dynamic enough like we could make this
larger the problem is that's a lot of
code for that like arguably we don't
need this that was just for debugging
purposes but we needed all that so what
can we do instead right so I'm gonna let
you guys in on a pretty big secret of
programmers and I probably shouldn't be
sharing it with you but I'm gonna share
it with you and it is called google.com
so this is how anybody writes JavaScript
I'm pretty sure okay so so anyways any
down votes on this video I know you are
a JavaScript programmer so anyway so how
can we use Google to our advantage one
thing we can do is check if all items in
list are same and we're using Python
guest Python for us so fine okay
cool we did a search because we didn't
know how to do this so rather than going
to Stack Overflow and posting our own
question or joining a discord and asking
such a Google question we just Google it
right that was really simple okay so
let's check the first answer awesome so
okay this person has really broken it
down um I feel like I feel like the
titles says enough performance he would
not like to incur any unnecessary
overhead okay so that's a lot of
information for a simple question okay
we've got a good deal of information
here some pretty confusing looking code
to be honest some sort of this looks
like it may be yeah I guess so at some
point you know you could use like a
generator or something so rather than
iterating over every single element as
soon as you find one
that doesn't match you could immediately
stop iterating you know have to waste
any further time okay we've got some
tape dude this is such a simple question
and man these people are going all out
okay so here we have a really simple
answer to the simple question
I do appreciate some of this stuff I
can't believe there's like tables of
times like who built this this is
hilarious but anyways yeah so we've got
a great answer not only that I mean
there is an abundance of information to
what I would describe as an unbelievably
simple simple question it was asked
eight years ago and honestly the answer
today looks to be pretty good there may
be like some sort of method nowadays if
there is I don't know it and like I said
before it you know you don't actually
always need the special method to do
these things but anyway this looks
pretty good
X dot count okay and we just see okay
does is the count of the first element
so so we count how many occurrences of
the you know the element in the zeroeth
position
how many occurrences are there and then
we see is that the same number as the
length of that list if so that means all
of them are the same so six times faster
than the set solution interesting so I
don't really know how dot count works
but it surely would have to iterate over
every item in the list but anyways
that's simple enough I think everybody
watching this can understand that one
also it's one line of code
so rather than this nonsense we could
just do Boop and then replace X with row
row and row okay then we asked if this
print winter run it and there we have
our winner now
one more thing we need to address is at
the start of the game everything is
zeroes so so like what if I do this
right right now there are no winners but
if we run this it's gonna say winner
right so we need one more final check
and that is and row zero does not equal
zero easy enough
let's run that one more time and we see
that no there is no winner
because the one row that did have
everything equal well that had zeros and
that's no good
okay so a lot of information there some
silly mistakes on my behalf but that's
okay
I'm gonna go ahead and leave those in
there I think it's good especially on a
basics tutorial to kind of go over the
confusing bits but I think that's it so
if you guys have questions comments
concerns whatever feel free to leave
them below and aside from our sponsor in
the video I appreciate the most recent
other channel sponsors Luiz Fernando I
can't say the Macedo I don't know
Reginald Roberts
that's a interest that's a good sounding
name ritesh naiyeer a cross and nut and
I am it's annoying yeah I you I don't
know that's a that's a challenging one
I'm not sure how you pronounce the O I a
bit comment below if you see this I'm
curious okay thank you guys very much
for your support helps me do what I love
to do which is this so questions
comments whatever feel free to leave
below otherwise in the next video we're
going to be solving the next easiest
version of this challenge which is the
vertical winners because diagonal is
gonna be kind of annoying but doing the
vertical is
doable I think most people probably
watching this could think of various
ways at least maybe not the most
efficient way but a way to do it so
that's we're gonna be doing in the next
video I will see you there